بعد كثير من الشائعات ووسط صدامات لا
تنتهي مع زملائه عمالقه التك الاخرين
اعلنها صراحه الملياردير الى الماسك انه
قد يفكر بانتاج هاتف جديد هاتف يهدد ايفون
تصريحات مس كانت ردا على تساؤل من صحيفه
استفزته قائله ماذا سيفعل الرجل الذي يصنع
الصواريخ اذا ازيل تطبيق تويتر للمتجر ابل
وجوجل كما ياتي اعلان ماسك بعد ان حذف
المسؤول عن اداره متجر التطبيقات في ارض
حسابه من على تويتر وطبعا كل هذه تبيعات
التغييرات التي قام بها ماسك بعد التواليه
اداره تويتر اثاره جدلا واسعه
موضوعها
ان تم انتاجه سيكون مجهزه بامكانياته
مذهله كل حال مزيد حول خلافات ماسك في
عالم التقنيه اليك
لطالما كان الخلاف والاختلاف عنوان عريضا
لازمات الى الماسك مع الاخرين من عمالقه
السوق التقنيه العالميه اخر الخلافات كانت
بين ايرون ماسكو وبيل جيتس حول بيع اسهم
تسلا حيث وجها ماسك انتقادا حادا لجيت
بسبب بيعه لاسهم في شركه تسلا وكان انتقده
مسبقا بسبب شرائه سياره بورش كهربائيه
بدلا من شرائه سياره من تسله وعلى مدى
سنوات كانت الازمات والهجوم في تصاعد بين
ماسك ومارك زوربربي حول مواضيع متنوعه مثل
الذكاء الاصطناعي والصواريخ نسيم ازمه
انفجار صاروخ تابع لسبيس اكس والتصريحات
مالك سكرت حول خيبته من فشل شركه مصر ايضا
خلاف ماسك مع ابل ليس جديده
بصناعه الهواتف والاجهزه اللوحيه بانها
تمارس الاحتكار قدام منافسيها وبعد استحوا
به على تويتر بشكل رسمي كان ماسك على موعد
مع خلافات حاده مع موظفي شركه العملاقه
الذي نتعرض للفصل التعسفي من قبل الملك
الجديد بعد رفتهم العمل بشروطه الجديده
[موسيقى]
على كل من الرياض ينضم لنا المؤثر والمهتم
بتقنيه فيصل سيف فيصل يسعد صباحك دوم اهلا
بك معنا في صباح العربيه دائما
[موسيقى]
يا رب العالمين
خلافات اكثر من اي حاجه مساله اظهار ظهور
اعلاني اكثر من اي شيء طبيعي الحالي اذا
احد من الصحفيين يستفز اي شخص على تطبيق
موجود معه فبالتالي عدم تواجد هذا التطبيق
على متجر يعني خط بديله خطه بديله يمكن
تكون ناجحه او ما يمكن تكون ناجحه ولكن
يمكن انها تطرح وهي للهاتف البديل الهاتف
بديل امر جدا ممكن اي شركه تقدر تطرحها
كثير من الشركات ولكن ولا شركه تنجح الا
بالاسرار الاساسيه للعبه او نقدر نقول
بالتركيبه الاساسيه لا نفس النجاح اللي ما
اظن ابدا همم
طيب فيصل في نقاش مثار للسنوات بانه شركه
ابل في طور تطوير صناعه السيارات ذاتيه
القياده والسيارات الكهربائيه يعني هل يحق
لابل ان تتدخل في مجال صناعه السيارات ولا
يحق لمسك ان يدخل على خط انتاج الهواتف
المماثله لابل مثلا
لو تكلمنا عن حقيقيه هذا المجال حيكون
الشركات اللي بعضها عمرها اكثر من 100 سنه
في هذا المجال ان تكون هي اساس قياده
السيارات الكهربائيه او الدخول في مجال
صناعات وسيارات الكهربائيه ولو تكلمنا عن
ما هو فعليا بخيل في هذا المجال وايضا
الشركات التقنيه ولكن في عام او في عالمنا
الجديد لما التقنيه هي اللي تكون اساس
الصناعات بالفعل سوني دخلت مجال السيارات
الكهربائيه نتكلم على شركه توشيبا وغيرها
من الشركات التقنيه اللي قاعدين يطوروا في
السيارات الكهربائيه فهذا ابدا مو شيء ما
له حقيقيه بالعكس ابل قاعده تسوي الشاي
الصحيح يكون هي عندها علامه تجاريه ضخمه
عندها مركز ابحاث وتطوير وعندها الكثير من
الكفاءات اللي تخليهم بكل بساطه ينتجوا
السياره لان الموضوع صار ابسط من زمان
هاتف ماسك كده داخل اتوقع اكبر حاجه حتصير
في انه يحاول يحفز المطورين انهم يطلعوا
تطبيقات على نفس المتجر الخاص بهاتف ماسك
لانه اذا طلع متجر تطبيقات موازي همم
ويشابه نقدر نقول انه متجر جوجل او متجر
ابل هنا حنعرف انهم مستحيل النجاح شبه
مستحيل النجاح شركه زي مايكروسوفت فشلت
انه جوالها يكون اساسي في العالم رغم وجود
متجر ضخم للتطبيقات ولو كلكم يعني واحد في
الاستديو اي واحد بالمشاهدين سالته هل
ممكن تستغني عن كل تطبيقاتك عشان تطبيق
واحد تضمنه اللي هو تويتر اكيد ما هو هذا
الشيء فبالتالي كون وجود مطورين
اللي احنا نبغاها طيب علشان جوال ماسك ما
اظن هيصرف بشكل
سريع منذ سنوات للسيطره على شركه ابل انت
فيصل كمخصص بالتقنيه هل تعتقد بانه كانت
ابل هذه الشركه العملاقه تحتاج لشخص مثل
الى الماسك
شركه
الضخمه التقنيه مايكروسوفت وغيرها ما
تحتاج شخص يكون الاعلام هو الوسيله او احد
وسائل الاساسيه في تلاعب في الشركات بين
اظهارها وبين وضع اختفاقات عليها وغيرها
من الامور امر شفناها تاريخيا سنوات
الماضيه قد يرى جده البعض حميدان
مره كويس عن نفسي الاقي انه لما يكون
الاعلام هو بوابه
الجدل على اسهم او على شركه عشان اقدر
اوقف فيها اكثر ايجابي او سلبي شوف انه
التخطيط الاستراتيجي افضل واهم وهذا الامر
اللي ما الاقيه بشكل كامل الناس وعلى فكره
بس من باب التوضيح الادمن مبتكر عنده
اشياء جدا كويسه ولكن ايضا عندهم كثير من
الاختلاقات التقنيه والاختفاقات في
المشاريع حقته
ما هو الاعلامي احد الاشياء اللي يسعلها
دائما مع كل مشروع الا اذا لقى ان المشروع
ما حيطلع بعده العالم ان شاء الله ماسك
مجتمعك على الصبح يا فيصل تسلم المؤثر
المهتم بتقنيه فيصل سيف شكرا جزيلا لك
دائما